ladies and gentlemen welcome to the tim
dillon show i'm here joined by uh old
friend of the program
podcaster
hilarious person uh ray kump is with us
hello thank you for having me thank you
uh
getting over
covet 19 baby i finally got it
were you did you eat a pangolin
i
i don't know how i got it but i just um
it was probably just because every
everybody i know has it everyone in la
has it
it's this you're vaccinated so it's it's
you know it's helping you
i mean you know what's so funny is no
you could tell that no one has any trust
in the vaccine because as soon as you
tell people you have it they're like oh
my god
oh my god and i'm like well i'm
vaccinated i'm supposed to be okay right
you're like dude be careful literally
people were texting me like be care i'm
like and these are the same people they
were like you got to get faxed
as soon as you get it they're like how
long do you have yeah they're like it's
my aunt texting me she's like it's scary
it's very scary i'm like i thought
the whole idea
was that you got the vaccine so that you
you wouldn't you wouldn't be inundated
with texts like are your affairs in
order
no one wants
people are addicted to
the death drama now yes no one we can't
go back we're not going to go back to
like you know occasionally someone dies
and we're fighting we just live our
lives if people don't have a death every
day to talk about or someone dying or
someone in the hospital they're going to
lose their minds it gives their lives
meaning yeah it gives you a lot of
culture now yeah it's a death culture
it's a good point and what's interesting
about
um having this is it is you know
worrisome you know you try to stay off
the internet when you have it right
because there's always like a case
there'll always be something to read
about
where you go oh [ __ ] you know right
um some there's always someone who's
died of everything like everything out
there you could die of someone has right
and
what's interesting about coven now is
people act like it's the only thing
killing people in america right like
it's the only thing this is a country
okay that has mass shootings an insanely
high homicide rate an opioid crisis
school shootings all the time uh insane
rates of cancer heart disease all kinds
of problems um suicide ptsd
untreated mental illness horrible roads
traffic accident but people act like
covet is just the only danger out there
cops are fighting hookers with like
their throats cut going look over it's
getting nasty
which way which variant is this yeah
which variant is this where i shoot an
innocent black guy in a 7-eleven parking
lot
what varian is that i don't know
um
you know i went so i went i got this
monoclonal antibody infusion which
really helps it's the same thing they
gave to trump
and uh you know being bigger now i'm
gonna try to really lose weight now
because this is not going anywhere
covered clearly and it's just gonna
survive why lose the weight
well i just think it's still it's a
better idea i got to prepare for
whatever the next variant is going to be
sure
the next variant's going to be like this
it's going to be hilarious you're going
to be like
not only does the vaccine not help the
next variant it hurts
they're gonna be like are you vaccinated
well then the next variant's gonna [ __ ]
you up watch the [ __ ] out
right
so uh i i went and i got this monoclonal
antibody infusion it's made by a company
called regeneron
which is um
the thing that trump got now i don't
know why it's not widely available it is
kind of like a miracle
drug i feel much better in in under 48
hours really i felt better in 24 hours
i mean it's hard to mass-produce when
you're based out of uh argentina using
old nazi science right
well
well what's good about texas is all the
doctors here are queuing on so they'll
literally
they'll do anything right
like when i went in the doctor's like
did you get back i was like yeah he was
like all right like he wasn't like good
for you or he goes ah all right
and then he goes like this he goes you
want survivor mektin
and i went well i don't know
and he goes how about this he calls me
up he goes why don't you go to a website
it's going to tell you all about the
ivormectin
he didn't even say like he didn't say
what iver mech thing is he's just like
he's like he's like watch the trailer
yeah
he's like have you seen zeitgeist
[Laughter]
uh no he he goes he calls me because how
are you doing after the antibodies i
said good
uh he goes okay because you want some
ivermectin and i went well i don't
really know i'm like
i don't know that i need it i feel
better he goes listen just go to this
website and it'll tell you all about it
he goes these doctors he goes they're
highly
peer reviewed he goes they're well
published he goes they're well known and
he goes so i go to the website and and
i'm not saying anything about ivermectin
i'm sure it has success and the people
that believe it or whatever but like
brett weinstein's being interviewed on
this website
bray weinstein's not a doctor though
he's not a doctor he's not he's perhaps
a doctor of something but whatever he's
like not a doc so it's very interesting
like
what
i'm looking at youtube link it's
[Applause]
i if you want to take ivermecting link
in bio yeah no it's it's literally a
[ __ ] i forget what it's called it's
called it's like the kovid coalition or
something
oh that's that i forget the name of it i
i wish i had the name of it right and
it's like the um
let me try to find it
and uh it's a website where they just
have all these different
there's garyvee on there
okay it's called covetcriticalcare.com
flccc alliance frontline coven 19
critical care alliance
we thank you for your continued support
this is going to remind me of the
mortgage crisis so if you go to this it
just is like a bunch of
interviews with people and one of them
is
dr pierre cory and paul marek discuss
the suppression of good science and more
with brett weinstein
dr corey on how ivermectin defeats the
variance blah blah blah so
it's just so funny i was like okay i've
never been told by a doctor before to go
to a website
you know why though is because when the
trial happens and it's like and so you
advise mr dylan to take ivermectin no
you're no uh actually to clarify i sent
him to a website he made his own
decisions
he says no there's no doctor advice
going
it's like he's selling you a speed ball
yeah the doctor calls me because listen
we've had a lot of success with a new
drug have you heard of the compound
media network
i want you to log on to compound media
and uh i mean listen maybe it works i
don't know but i mean i i feel better my
oxygen levels are good i walk walking
two or three miles a day
um
did you take the effortmectin no i have
a script for it i picked it up i was
like hey if i if i felt bad i was gonna
take it right it's like seven pills a
day or something
that's that's a lot of pills it's a lot
of pills um but i made it through but
you you've never had this as far as you
know
kovid no i'm i'm uh i'm a very healthy
man and i've managed to keep it uh keep
it up at bay
with my uh physical acumen
well and you don't leave your home
i leave occasionally i mean i go out to
dinner i go to the movies
i've seen four or five movies since they
reopened how 1950s of you like i go to
the dinner i go to the movies
you know no but i i walk around and yeah
my girlfriend lucy she walks you know
she leaves the house a lot so you know
if she caught it i would get it
so you know i mean it's uh i think it's
not it's not tearing through new york at
the moment but yeah i'm sure it will
at some point yeah again the doctor
calls me back and he goes i want you to
watch a documentary
sit down
just sit down you know that jesus that
jesus is actually based on the sumerian
myth
anyway take this pill
do you know
that jesus was based on horus
do you know that oh interesting that's
very interesting i'm like can you take
my blood pressure he goes sit down sit
down and relax for a little bit okay
you know our money is not backed by gold
did you know that
it's backed by nothing
you understand
it's like hey what's what are my uh what
are my platelets account look like oh uh
you know debt is slavery
i'm a bitcoin maximalist
you know it's the only way to keep the
government in check i'm like i
understand is my oxygen good is it above
95 how what's the thermite paint
[Laughter]
it's also some of these doctors in texas
you go where did you go to school like
because some of them go to like texas
christian academy of jesus you know
well the weird thing is like don't a lot
of them go over like i know when people
come from other countries they like
can't their medical license can't
transfer for some reason but like aren't
a lot of those guys don't they go down
to like south america to get their
licenses a lot of the times
isn't there a thing that they go to
brazil where they go they're like is
that true i didn't know that i don't
know or like or like some i think
there's like i think there's like med
schools in the cayman islands that like
some of these guys go to
um
next to the banks that like you know for
all the money
i mean listen i'm happy though i got the
antibody infusion like i am glad that
they were like let's throw everything at
it
yeah no one's taking chances with you no
one no one thinks you're fighting it off
on your own
that's not true i'm white
this is disproportionately affecting
people that are non-white because they
don't get the uh
the blood of the children injected into
them like you did well i was given it
because it's given it there is a group
in texas called
the society for the preservation of
white men
and
that's who that's literally i'm not even
kidding that's who gave me the the
infusion that's who paid for it what
it that's who paid for the infusion
i swear to you
why
it's it's it's about preserving european
heritage
um
that sounds sketchy
is it
a little bit
i'm not sure what we're getting out of
here
[Music]
that's the reason i was able to get this
it said
to preserve the lineage of europeans
i mean is are you really what they want
to preserve
this is what this is i don't i don't ask
you know
i don't ask um
what's going on in uh in new york
um you know it's it's
it's fine i mean there's a lot more
uh homeless under the overpasses now but
you know they gotta go somewhere so you
have a camp style under like on meeker
avenue
uh
that's the biggest difference i see
um
any people just walking around some of
them have mass some don't everyone's
just kind of
living there uh
living their best life
yeah i haven't gotten stabbed yet
no i mean you know it's gonna it's gonna
take a while for this [ __ ] to write
itself it's very weird
and um
it's a very strange [ __ ] time
uh
to do anything
um you know or to plan anything you know
i mean i know that
a lot of people have tour i have a tour
i'm pretty sure that tours are going to
be okay
i think they'll just
you know basically
uh start requiring the vaccine
everywhere
as opposed to shutting things down
right that seems to be the direction
things are heading in other minds i have
to get my excelsior pass
what is that new york
excelsior passes you're proof i guess
that you have the vaccine and you'll
need that to get into clubs and uh
restaurants
uh because i'm a man about town so i'm
gonna need my excelsior pass
how are they gonna keep track of all
this like who is gonna be checking this
some goon
yeah so well look the same guy who
[ __ ] checks my id to go into some
shitty bar and it's like oh your license
is expired
when's the last time you've been id'd
i mean some of these borrowers i mean
they don't care they like you have to
have a license
passport
they'll literally check like an elderly
person they don't like because they're
morons they like these are people who
can't be trusted to like do normal like
to have judgment so like their bosses
tell them like no like just you know
molest that old woman and make sure she
you know she she's who she says she is
yeah this isn't a case by case you check
everybody
right
i just love the idea of somebody looking
at you and going this 17 year old thinks
she's going to get over on me
i don't know uh that um
any of this is gonna
actually be implemented in the way that
people want it to like you like i just i
just think it's gonna be pretty sloppy
and i think a lot of people are gonna
get lazy and go yeah whatever just come
in
right well it depends on the uh
it depends on the outfit i guess i mean
because they i guess they can be huge if
it happens right like they can be uh
it's hard to prove where you got it
right like it's very difficult to prove
how and where you got it but i guess
yeah the fear is litigious it's that you
could get sued
we should all just uh
i mean that's a good point like no one
there is no way we should all wear
sensors they should give you a sensor
like if i can like it goes in your arm
and just you know glows if you have
covered
how can they do that
how great would it be if tomorrow like
biden comes on tv it's like no vaccine
mandates
sensors in your arm
said glow
if you have government he goes we've
heard the civil libertarians we get it
we're not doing vaccine passports
sensors in your body that will glow
a lovely like iridescent blue
if you have goven
i mean look and then do with you people
can be you know you have informed
consent then you can go i'm going to
avoid this man or i'm going to i'm going
to have sex with him either one certain
people are afraid of getting chips put
in them you want it
i mean as long as they're functional i
mean you know those things that like
that amazon has these little buttons
that you can hit to order more like risk
crackers there will be a period of fun
because we clearly are becoming these
hybrids
but there's going to be some real
there's going to be some real chaos
before we're perfected
i look people like the people who uh uh
stew stewart the most whatever the word
would be uh who who poo poo on this uh
this biomechanic stuff or people who
could use i could use a mechanical
thyroid it would help me yes you know
like just shove a car like a car battery
into my neck and like get my metabolism
well the whole idea is if they do that
to you and then you decide to overthrow
the government
uh with your group of freedom fighters
they can turn you off because they have
a they're they've they've hacked you
they can hack you but they they can't
even keep like you know uh russian
hackers from turning off the damn like
they're gonna like
i i could hack my my neck implant
probably also if they give you a neck
implant why would you overthrow the
government yeah they're doing me a favor
i'm in the best shape of my life he just
wants a neck implant
it is very interesting let's say we're
all bionic and we're all running around
and like we feel and look great and
everything's regulated by a mainframe
computer there's probably no reason to
have a revolution
yeah like you know people want to [ __ ]
they want to eat and they want to
you know enjoy a show every once in a
while no but if you listen to america
this is a country of
hardcore freedom fighters
yeah but it is because like there's no
jobs and there's no shows and there's no
you know they took away everything good
yeah no one was no one was rebelling
when we were just you know eating steaks
all day no one cared about freedom when
there was game of thrones and you could
sit inside of chili's
yeah right that's nice yeah there's free
this freedom is a
freedom's really it's it's it's what you
have when things aren't going great
we used to talk about how like you know
a few years ago even just like oh
they'll never rebel because you know we
have the ipod's too good we're the
iphone and like and the food's too like
plentiful and like they're they're
losing the like the bare fundamentals of
what kept this thing going like just
feed everyone fat and and solve and like
[ __ ] like you know and give them a
good show every once in a while and now
they can't even do that well the woke
[ __ ] is ruined entertainment so you
don't have any entertainment
yeah i can't believe that the cia is
look if it is a cia op there's a short
sight they have look forget like
agencies not talking to each other the
different parts of the cia got to talk
to each other right there's woke
division who's like screwing up the mind
control division yeah no it's true it's
the biggest
[ __ ] like short play in history where
you're going to like you're going to
literally cause
a group of people who've been docile
their entire life to now start thinking
about like serious anti-government
activity because every time they turn on
tv they're being scolded
right they're being do you think was
there some
argument going on in some back room or
it's like why did you kill epstein they
were eating pudding right
like they don't give a [ __ ] they don't
care
okay that was the thing
it's a good point
like what if epstein was just convinced
to like hang three
somewhat irrelevant guys like he went
out and he was like okay it was new
mexico governor bill richardson it was
some creepy physicist and give him some
celes some like low-level celeb and be
like it was uh toe for grace toe for
grace
that's who it was
and then everyone in america would be
like [ __ ]
god damn it toe for grace
and then and it's it and then that's it
and then he goes to like some federal
prison
but they couldn't chance that dad they
they they had to get rid of them but do
you get sad
i mean sometimes you know sure
but because of the variance you're also
like i can't go to a therapist
no i look i mean how can i i can't leave
my house i'm worried about getting
covered this is a catch-22
well
do you sometimes wish there was a
service
where you could get help
for your problems
i'm going to tell you i'm going to give
you a miracle
better help
b-e-t-t-e-r
better help better help
that sounds that sounds that sounds
great
betterhelp.com
you know what they do
it's online therapy you could start
communicating in under 48 hours it's not
a crisis line you're not in crisis okay
you can log into your account anytime
dare night and send a message to your
counselor you'll get timely and
thoughtful responses it's more
affordable than traditional offline
counseling and financial aid is
available
who are these people they're better help
and they want you to start living a
happier life today
i'll try
visit betterhelp.com timdy that's better
atlp and join the over 1 million people
who've taken charge of their mental
health with the experience with the help
of an experienced professional in fact
so many people have been using better
help that they are recruiting additional
counselors in all 50 states this podcast
is sponsored by betterhelp and tim
dillinger listeners get 10 off their
first month at betterhelp.com
tim d if you have an online business you
need to ship things and ship station is
the way to do it have you ever shipped
anything online ray
yeah and i've gotten you know it's it
can be a real hassle a real burden you
don't know how to do it
i'm really bad at that sometimes i just
like duct tape a a bunch of items and
they try to send it in the mail and it
gets lost
it ruins my life don't you wish there
was like a back order
uh a back office
a digital online back office that kept
track of all of your orders
all of your shipments
worked with all the major carriers
allowed you to focus on growing your
business while they focused on all of
the other
very intricate parts
sure they also love a million dollars
but you know how's that gonna happen
well i'll tell you how to make a million
dollars it's work with ship station no
matter how you sell shopify etsy your
own website
[Music]
ship station
ship station funnels all your orders
into one simple interface
you can manage from anywhere
even your skills i think are they going
to get nosy about what i'm shipping i
don't think so it's none of their
business i don't think it is you'll even
get access to amazing discounts with
major carriers ups fedex usps easily
compare carriers and choose the best
solution every time
ray with ship stations small businesses
can now access the same rates usually
reserved for fortune 500
companies
without the contract you might be
sitting there going why am i not
coca-cola
and i'll tell you why you're not
coca-cola because of the shipping
it's
yeah am i indemnified in case one of
these guys uh you know does something
during delivery am i am i gonna be
liable my company i don't know you talk
to a lawyer but here's what i will tell
you
it's the shipping stupid remember that
quote
from what
shipping is essential is my point and if
you're not doing it
appropriately
it's going to be bad for you
really got a ship product all right so
you don't have a choice just go with
these people
shipstation.com
click on the microphone at the top of
the page then type in tim dillon
that shipstation.com enter offer code
tim dillon make ship happen
they're discreet
we all have passions that push us to do
big things in life like selling your
crafts online
all out of a deep burning love for
logistics and order management
okay
no one's passionate about that part
that's why there's ship station
ship more in less time for a lot less
money just use my offer code tim dillon
to get a 60-day free trial
that's two months free of no hassle
stress-free shipping
yeah i mean
it's strange
because i hear about people i'm also
concerned about
the the type of vaccine passport
uh you know
architecture they could build
um i'm sure i get it we all get it right
but
it's just
it's so already down the road and not to
celebrate it coming but it's so ready
here with your phone with tech
with the ability to kick you off the
internet with the ability to really kick
you off payment processors right
so you get the guy going oh no i'm on
android i'm fine right right
it's already here and not that we should
celebrate it and i'm not saying to
welcome it with open arms but it is
interesting that people that like
aren't aware of how
down the road we are on a lot of this
stuff
yeah and what we were saying for years
and we were late on the tube it's not
like we were looking with pioneers but
like
the time for like doing anything was you
know probably 20 years just like climate
change probably 20 years ago right
we just can't like it would be hilarious
if we did have a revolution like like
the day before everything collapses
basically well we see what a revolution
looks like right it's a guy in a viking
helmet running around taking selfies
that was an american revolution make no
mistake even though it wasn't a
revolution and it was laughable
that was just about
the level of revolution you're gonna see
in this country adults
wearing costumes taking selfies
in the congress and putting them up as
their facebook profile pictures that's
about the level
of of real
revolutionary activity you're gonna see
can you imagine like trotsky
photocopying his [ __ ] and just racing
on the wall
right he's just sitting on a photocopier
like what are you doing leon he's like
shut the [ __ ] up
he's taking photocopies of his ass he's
like we'll show him
i mean that's kind of where we're at
though i mean like you know when you
look at the january 6th thing and you go
that's that's pretty much
the most you're going to see because if
not then why didn't you see more then
yeah well i mean it's
you it's coming from so many different
angles too is a weird thing like you
know the miss like
misinformation basically like the level
i mean the level of uh the kind of
people you're gonna get for a stop to
steal type thing when there really was
no
any reason to believe it like it was
right you're gonna get the real yahoos
so the chance
that like you know
when we stop when we stop saving babies
in the hospital which we will we'll just
we'll just you know we'll just kill
babies in the hospital you know when
they get the flu uh or whatever i'm just
saying there's levels of like of decay
that's gonna happen despite the
infrastructure bill uh you might get a
little more wise yeah the infrastructure
bill that's the fix it's the big fix
but um you know i'm saying you might you
might get a little more of a
of a sampling of a different you know
well you see you sit on the west coast
you see portland seattle you see the ant
of people you see like people that try
to bomb some courthouses
you know they show up outside of
politicians houses and stuff and but
then the cops go and club them you know
what was the last time there's an actual
terrorist attack that wasn't you know i
mean of course the
you know the mass shootings are just
individuals who have nothing to do with
any kind of uh concerted you know
conspiracy but you know
wink but uh yeah
deal the last terrorist attack was the
very not shady boston marathon and
before that it was the very not shady
911 and before that it was the very not
shady oklahoma city bombing that's where
the enemy is so much more had no idea
about anything that was happening either
of those times despite mountains of
evidence to the contrary the fact that
they were the half the population of
elohim city yeah i mean despite having
successful infiltrations and all those
groups and an insane amount of yourself
what'd you say can you infiltrate
yourself right i mean no but i mean they
they had surveillance capability
uh on on on every person
who was involved
pretty much in all of those attacks
the vast majority of those people uh it
does seem like sketchy like those people
just seem more waco seem more serious
and like the
oklahoma city bombing seymour like what
i mean i i do kind of take some pause
from like you know the level of
discourse in this country and things are
getting you know weird and cr and bad
but that being said it does seem more
clownish than it used to be like every
every everyone even the white
supremacists even the and even the
militant comment everyone just seems
more clownish
yeah well because i think i think it's a
i i think it's dawning on everybody that
this doesn't
get better
right like i think that that's something
that people are starting to
there's a capitulation
um whether it's knowingly or unknowingly
to the new reality to the new normal to
the idea that the violence is not gonna
stop
uh the you know the the the pandemic is
gonna roll on and be what it's gonna be
the uh
the
gridlock in government and public health
policy
the
edicts and mandates that are handed down
that are selectively enforced
the politicians that you know have these
lavish birthday parties maskless while
requiring masks uh all of this is never
gonna stop it's gonna stop in maybe a
few years when delta is gone but they
will have another problem
maybe not a public health problem but
we'll have climate issues like you know
these fires in california you have these
serious climate problems right right um
and then what's gonna happen you're
gonna have the elite go stay inside on
wednesday because the [ __ ] air is not
good how dare you and then what they're
going to wednesday they're going to be
having a luau
because they're going to have like an
oxygen tan up and they're all going to
be partying and that's not gonna change
because the planet is becoming less and
less hospitable so what they're trying
to do is figure out ways to keep the lid
on things like barely while they can
dance and do conga lines and [ __ ] kids
on epstein's island like they're just
trying to figure out
how to keep it all
from bleeding out into the street do you
think this is purely speculative but do
you think over the next few decades the
level of luxury for these people
declines as well
no
no i think it'll actually become more
technologically advanced like they will
start purifying oxygen like
the level of luxury is only going it may
decline in the sense that like it may be
less important to have an opulent
mansion
than it is to have a well-guarded
compound with your own hospital like
you're not going to have a beautiful you
know you made your sandstone you may
need your own er
now
so that may be the new luxury it may be
like how many wings does your house have
it goes well we have one wing and it's a
cardiac wing like we have our doctor
like
that may be the new luck the new luxury
may be having like as these systems fail
which kind of interesting to think about
like as these systems fail
rich people may start thinking how much
of this can we do at home
the new yacht will be a school bus
buried underground with guns inside yes
perhaps
you know
i mean i do think then you're gonna also
have
you know air quality issues you're
having a lot of air quality issues on
the west coast
right and that won't stop these fires
are not going to stop so
it's good it's already dystopian but
what's the next level after dystopian
um
just armageddon like apocalypse i mean
you know
flying hordes like horses of the grim
reapers here's what i don't understand
and maybe this is the vaccine and we'll
all realize this eventually but like me
and you have always said why don't they
just start giving people drugs
yeah well like why
why can't they give you something in the
mail that you could take that at least
makes this seem more fun
i mean is it any is it a coincidence of
the mortgage crisis and the iraq and
afghanistan wars and the torture
coincided with like the you know uh the
oxycontin crisis no it was like listen
yeah we're torturing people and blowing
up [ __ ] who gives a [ __ ] get a pool
you can afford it now
you can afford to drown in your own
backyard
take this pill and go in your pool
it doesn't look i i understand the
forest is dry can't they like i i i know
it's a problem i don't know why they
can't i don't know why they can't but
every year it burns it's they can't they
can't bring sprinklers into it and just
wet it i mean it was like a lack of
water but like
the ocean just dump ocean water whatever
it doesn't work there's too many acres
of wick forest ready to just burn at any
moment it's just hot it's dry and hot
you get those hoe you know those hoses
that they make that like yeah that
irrigate usually they seep out the sides
of the hose just get get some of that
yeah what's this infrastructure all
about then we don't need another bridge
we just need to get some hoses
i mean when you drive around flint
michigan or when you drive around any of
these places you go
more and more of the country is probably
going to start to look like that
did they ever fix the water did they
i don't know
i didn't drink any water it would be
amazing if they fix the do all those
infrastructure stuff they never fix
flint well they probably won't but right
more and more of america will start to
look like those places because
people are just gonna leave cops will
leave
cops go i don't want to do this [ __ ]
gig right if they if they have any other
option um
and then you have like
you know
flight people just leaving and then and
then the people that are stuck there are
gonna have to live in these hellish
conditions and then you know these
become like a no man's land where people
just don't go and
you know i think
unfortunately over the next 20 30 years
50 years whatever
you're just gonna see more i mean
sikorsky helicopters keep large
percentages of connecticut employed
if they leave
connecticut becomes to detroit parts of
it
right
so yeah and people still worry about the
taliban because like oh like
it fosters terrorism what do you think
it's going to happen in your ring of
detroit that's right
people don't know [ __ ]
right people don't understand yeah what
happened to ghost towns like people used
to when it all dried up people used to
leave why i know people have it rough
but i mean like
should we be relocating these people get
them out like you know if the whole
thing's done which i get we're not
making cars anymore let's get out joe
biden comes out tomorrow he goes
two things this government's gonna do
number one
in your arm will be a sensor that will
glow
if you come and [ __ ] if you have
coronavirus number two we're doing the
flint relocation project
where we're we're randomly picking
people to adopt a family from flint
michigan
yes we should be relocating these people
but the problem is
there's not a lot of places to relocate
them to like dude if you go to cleveland
ohio right
if you go to places like omaha nebraska
if you go to if you drive around this
country enough
the new yorks and chicagos and miami
and la these are the anomaly
the venus can we just take them because
like cincinnati doesn't like oh look
people are going to hate me for it but
cincinnati doesn't really need to be
where it is and neither is cleveland and
neither is like omaha can we just make
like one or two like nice cities out of
them like like just bringing home how do
you make the nice cities
you you get you you get a couple you get
look i'm sorry you get a foxconn we'll
build another foxconn we're gonna do it
anyway i mean
you might be right
you give some you you have people what
we look we got outward robots
and we gotta outlaw
uh
you do need large factories for like
people so they could do math and like
work yeah i mean you look drugs used to
help when you you don't think doc
workers used to you know uh of course do
heroin of course he did no we demonize
drugs and we've demonized
um
the idea of like the working man a
working man should get a fair wage to to
work in a factory and
do speed
the time when this country was built
right like the 1800s when like we we
fetishize the gilded age and all those
guys everyone was drunk
that's right like the amount of people
that's why prohibition happened for a
reason because everyone was just
plastered all the time on like cider or
whiskey or whatever no one was drinking
water and it was the most productive
time in american history except maybe
post-war america but that you know
uh i'm just saying like you know we used
to have a great relationship with drugs
and alcohol and and and this puritanical
uh screed that we've gone on has ruined
it nancy reagan ruined this country
nancy really just said no just say no to
the jobs apparently i gotta i gotta get
my kitchen floor i just had tile done i
gotta have it redone because you're
right it looks dirty there it looks like
streaks of dirt oh yeah like you just
went on a hike in the woods looks filthy
it's just the type of tile looks filthy
i don't want i don't want my house to
look like i live in flint
after being like after having just a
discussion about how bad the world's
getting i'm like i gotta have the floor
read that but what do you want me to do
i'm just being honest
i mean is it uh is it is it as an
ethically sourced tile
sure but i i i have to now i have to
just
you know
i i told the company i don't want to
work with them anymore
i i i said i'll pay you for the
materials but just drop it off at the
house i don't want i don't like the way
the guy laid the tile i don't like any
of it also the guy who you were talking
about on the show last week or whatever
he's wearing laid to tile no he hired
some guy i just didn't love it but it's
really more the actual tile looks dirty
yeah no the first thing i thought was
you know you were on facetime i thought
it was a facetime but no it's like
streaks of like you know it looks like
mud no it's bad it's really disgusting
these people are disgusting
and um but that's a look down here like
dirty kitchen floor
that's kind of a look here this is like
ranch hands and you know people are just
different things where you're living
before everyone's pretending to have
horses no these people are legit those
people these people are real the deal
you know as opposed to pretending after
spending last summer on the sidelines
we're all ready to get back out there
and make this year's lounge season an
epic one bespoke post is here to take
your sand sun and surf came to the next
level you like getting presents in the
mail have you ever tried the box of
awesome here's what you get you get a
different box every single month with
cool stuff ray each box costs only 45
and it has 70 worth of gear inside
gear what kind of gear anything you want
batman gear all kinds of stuff if you go
outside they have things for you to go
outside with
sometimes yes
travel outdoor gear summer styles
grooming goods breezy summer styles
so maybe they'll give you like a breezy
summer style shirt and a knife this
sounds like that movie battle royale
everyone gets a different weapon how
cool was that movie that was a great
movie so maybe this is pretty damn cool
it's free to sign up and you can skip a
month to cancel any time
you get a different box every month
you understand are you with me
you look like you're getting confused
okay
how many guns do i need
the heart sending you guns
they send you really cool stuff you can
tell them what you like and they'll send
you all kinds of cool stuff it's a fun
it's a fun surprise
what is this
where do we live
hold
on
it's free to sign up skip a month cancel
any time
get twenty percent off your first
monthly box when you sign up at box of
awesome dot com and enter the code tim
dillon at checkout that box of
awesome.com enter the code tim dylan for
20 off your first box keeps hair care
you need to keep the hair
it's
it's a simple stress-free way to keep
your hair convenient virtual doctor
consultations and medications delivered
straight to your door every three months
you do not have to leave your home low
cost treatments start at ten dollars per
month and keeps offers generic versions
discrete packaging and proven results
keeps us more five-star reviews than any
of its competitors prevention is key
treatments can take four to six months
to see results so act fast if you're
ready to take action and prevent hair
loss are you
i mean i think that that ship has sailed
well you should have used keeps
k-e-e-p-s dot com
slash tim dillon receive your first
month of treatment for free that's
k-e-e-p-s dot com slash tim dillon to
get your first month free k-e-e-p-s dot
com slash tim dillon first month free
and if you don't believe me there's a
website i can send you to
is brett weinstein
supplemental dude how funny would it be
if they had you on the show
like like brett and heather and you just
sat like between them and just like
played with your teeth as they talked
with my teeth hello play with your
nipples yeah and you go you go i have a
nervous tic
can i eat
keeps is so good keeps is uh important
here because you want everyone wants to
keep their real hair
i'd love some hair will grow back hair
you need to keep the hair you have right
now
i mean you know it's okay
i'll start i'll start taking it dude
haiti is getting rocked by earthquakes
they're the unluckiest country out there
kabul is on the brink what do you say
ray kabul is on the brink
look it's been i don't understand it's
been 20 years since 9 11 are we really
still worried about them doing
terrorism i mean look if they're not
morons and they learn their lesson like
hey it took us 20 years to get this back
maybe we don't have next bin laden
hanging out over here but they didn't
really
well they took the country over but if i
was taliban i'd be like look the one
thing we don't do is have terrorist
camps that's right vibrate at taliban
that's what i would do because now we're
back in charge they can't look but then
the italians gonna be like but they're
telling us the us is telling us
don't fall for it
don't grade point don't fall for it
you fell for it in the 80s you kept
falling for it through the 90s like
when we tell you we want to train and
arm radical elements of your society
don't go in for that
i mean has there ever been a country
maybe for i don't wanna like play the
typical you know uh
whatever but you know france is it gets
accused of laying down for the nazis but
like i'm saying afghanistan they don't
they don't seem to be doing anything at
least all the american officials are
saying like we trained them like we like
we did all this they're not doing
anything to stop this the afghan you
know provisional government whatever
they call it a regular government
or the armed forces i mean we've been
training them for 20 years at what point
are we like you know
yeah you got to defend your own country
maybe they just want you i mean it's a
great point michael tracy said on
twitter it's like how have we built this
thing that collapses in like a day
maybe maybe we were just spending the
whole last 20 years like growing opium
i also don't think we ever want any of
this to work
yeah
but we we we want a reason to go back
well we want the collapse i mean that's
maybe that's the thing maybe that's the
play is that like look we're gonna like
we're gonna go back but we need a year
or two where it gets real bad we're like
we can point to like look they're making
the women wear dog collars again we
can't allow this like you know it was
too good for too long in afghanistan
yeah
it's very strange and i don't know
what's gonna go down i just know that
we've got really a few peaceful years
left on this planet before it gets a
hell of a lot worse
um
and uh i just it's tough to tell people
that served the country
like the people that are joining the
military now say god bless them
i mean it's still better than working at
walmart i guess i guess you're right
that's a good point
that's not why he's not he's not getting
a job at ford
right
yeah i mean it's it's because now
there's we now know
like it's the proof is really out there
that like
nothing is is going to work
no i mean like
[ __ ]
should the armed forces now just have a
sign that says you will die in vain
like there's i mean no way
there's no way you won't dive in unless
somehow like you save a bait on one of
these missions that makes sense to no
one that's doomed to failure maybe you
like save a baby and that's your good
but pretty much
or you're chris kyle and you shoot the
baby right
dude so ben
ben
uh
goes out you know their friends in texas
and like all the people here in texas
think chris kazaka here like they like
they believe like everything you know
like they're just like they're like you
ever see the movie american snapper
you ever see it
you ever see that movie zero dart 30
what it's a clown show it's a it's uh
they'll hate the oh hey jesse ventura i
think he's a
american
scum yeah so what was
he's dead now right
chris kyle basically in his book said
that jesse ventura was like at some seal
funeral navy seal funeral and just like
saying the guy deserved to
die and like and have some fight with
him and like which is like even
look i know he goes on tv and talks
about the loch ness monster but i mean
the guy was like basically a seal like i
don't i don't think he's like just
eventually ventura alive or dead oh he's
alive okay yeah he's an interesting guy
to get on the show
oh he'd be great to talk to
yeah i mean you know i mean look just
don't ask him about the harp gun he gets
a little uh
things get a little hazy when you talk
about stuff like that but why i think he
knows
he's just like he doesn't really have a
he casts a wide net
what the weather gun is that what you
mean by the harp gun i'm just saying
he's only a strong filter i think he
wanted to fill that show up with like
you know
topics so like some good points about
about 9 11 and some other weird shows it
does yes i'm saying it's just you know
but then you might start going off that
way
but the harp gun is the real problem
there is a covent god would you like
jesse
say on stay on folks stay focused i take
ivermectin in my [ __ ]
it's not gay
it's what's going off about navy seals
navy seals are all deserved deserve what
they get
shield team six was a bunch of [ __ ]
[Laughter]
bin laden's an american [ __ ] hero
how great would it be if he just went
completely insane
i love osama bin laden and the bin laden
family
he's just doing like praying to mecca
yeah the only god is allah the only true
god is allah
he should open up we we should like
we should
we should see how far we can get
telling him we're like big investors and
that we want to open up a conspiracy
theory restaurant with him like directly
conspiracy fridays you'd get a meeting
like you'd absolutely get a meeting if
like you were like jesse we really want
to open up like a conspiracy
theory
conspiracy themed restaurant
like an applebee's or a fridays or an
outback you know but instead of like
boomerangs and kangaroos on the wall we
have like syringes pictures of building
seven and [ __ ] like you know
the northwoods nachos are my favorite
like things like that
mk ultra feast yes okay all true
i mean we all i always wanted to do
conspiracy theory line ice creams we
talked about it on the patreon but ice
cream is so hard you can can't do it you
can't ship it you can't make any money
i've always wanted to make my own line
of ice cream
that conspiracy hot sauce maybe no i i'm
sick of the sauces i can't taste
anything right now food is still good
which is how you know that like
you you have a problem with food is it
when you can't taste anything foods like
still you're still looking forward to it
people like how can you eat i'm like i
can eat you just don't taste it you just
keep eating
but
i'm eating a lot healthier now i'm just
eating nothing inflammatory because of
the covet which i think in a few days
i'll test negative
um
but
the uh
what you may call it the um
yeah i've always wanted to make a line
of ice creams and sell them but very
expensive
to a very small select group of people
like we'd have to literally we'd
probably have to charge something stupid
for a pint of ice cream
50 bucks something like that people
might buy it you got i think
well you had a great like we had some
good ideas about like jeffrey egg cream
where we'd have like
we'd have like an egg cream style ice
cream
with like um
like uh a fudge ripple and then like
little chocolate girls
or we'd have like the uh
sweet um
jet fuel doesn't melt sweet cream
and we'd have like a 911 themed ice
cream like we you know we had a whole
thing
controlled demo licorice something like
that joan bernier ramsay which had
beignets and they had a chicory coffee
swirl it was a new orleans theme even
though they're not from there but
you know
yeah
but you know we we we have but i think
if we got jesse ventura
like got his people
and we're like you know they still have
people i mean he's just some guy now
isn't he how do you start a business
it's a great question like all these
people that are like small business
owners how do you even start a business
like in this cut like how much ca you
need so much capital to just start
anything
oh your mortgage your house or your
parent's house it's usually happening i
mean for a small small business like
right
uh and it'll fail like you know i mean
like anyone who like lasts more than two
years nose can we take like a hundred
grand and just start a coffee house
that's gonna fail but it'll be hilarious
yeah i mean you know what i mean like
can i just release
a space and start
like a coffee house and like literally
do that like put crazy [ __ ] on a wall
like can we do all of that oh sure yeah
yes
yeah 100 but there's all the legal
things about hiring people but what if
we just hire our friends like devin and
i done
yeah i mean basically you just kind of
you know called uh
you you just call it uh
you hire him as models basically
interesting
yeah okay
so you can't you know they they just
work for hire
yeah it's not that like it's not what
like hooters does or someone or because
what if we really could succeed with
like a restaurant we just don't even
know it
yeah i mean just a bucket a bucket of
spaghetti it was real real real trash i
mean just you know no what if i'm not
kidding like what if we went to like
huntsville alabama and opened a
restaurant called bucket of spaghetti
no like hear me out
well you would get buckets of spaghetti
yeah and like different sauces like
there'll be a pesto sauce yes oh no
butter sauce
what'd you say peanut butter sauce yeah
that's not a bad idea um
peanut butter and jelly pasta
yeah
bucket
buckets we shouldn't even be talking
about this people are going to steal
this this is a good idea
wiley dufresne used to do peanut butter
pasta wd50 new york it was a very like
uh conceptual restaurant oh really
i think he did well here's the thing we
don't we don't have utensils
you have to just eat out of the bucket
like a pig like a trough
what if we had something called the
trough where like you had to put your
face in it
yeah i mean we
it'll be really fun if we just if we we
handcuff your hands behind your back to
the chair
like you just you just have to like
you're in a pie eating contest i don't
know if insurance would go in for that
no but i think like i'm like not even
kidding like i think like if you just
had a restaurant called bucket
and it was like bucket of nachos it's
called johnny buckets jolly buckets and
anything you want it's in a bucket
yeah
yeah you uh let me get you you could
choose let me get three chicken wings
uh a quarter pound of pasta some bread
some peanut butter and jelly and they
just put it in a bucket and then just
mash it together yeah bucket it's like
it's like it's like it's like stone cold
creamery yeah the drink yeah cold stone
the drinks are in a bucket
everything's in the bucket and it's
cardboard
it's better for the environment no
plastic
yeah
you put the drink the soda like in the
bucket together so there's only one big
slop yeah
it's bucket it's bucket life yeah and
and it'd be and and we'd sell shirts and
the shirts would say [ __ ] it i'm getting
a bucket
i wonder if kfc does that [ __ ] it i'm
getting a bucket probably not they
should i mean they they think they think
they're being a reference but they're
you know they're too much of a
it's cowardice um tell people where they
can find you you listen to the comp
podcast uh it's on youtube and wherever
you get podcasts very funny show uh
follow me on twitter and instagram at
ray kump um are you enlisting in the
military to fight uh how are you letting
them lose kabul
i've sent them shoes we start tweeting
at potus
why are you letting them lose
kabul this is
saigon all over again how dare you
it's going to be bad
yeah
i mean you know russia and china are
standing by them
why aren't they why why they hate us so
much like china at this point with the
uber euger muslims or whatever shouldn't
they like are you trying to get any
blame in this world anymore
why are we the great satan you know why
i think china just kind of just does it
and shuts up about it like we
we would do that to the weaker muslims
but then like we'd make like a movie
about how like we're like they're
working at the north pole
you know what i mean we do a movie about
how they're like santa's helpers and
then people would find out the reality
and they'd be like yeah they those
muslims they gave them jobs at the toy
shop and they'd be like no they didn't
they tortured the [ __ ] out of them so
when you find out what we're really
doing it's so strikingly different from
what we're purporting to do that people
get upset whereas china's just like yeah
i guess people got they got caught they
got tortured
and there's something i don't know maybe
there's something refreshing about that
probably
tim dillon.com timberland comedy where
we'll be back out on the road soon folks
thank you very much for listening god
bless you go follow raycomp thank you